i want to start with the thing that i
found
interesting about you is that i read
that you wanted to get into acting when
you were like six years old
uh yeah and i'm just curious what what
was it that you saw
that said i i want to go do that i
saw my older sister um was watching man
on fire with denzel washington and
dakota fanning
and um yeah i probably shouldn't have
been watching that when i was six years
old but my older sisters were watching
it my parents were at work whatever i
ended up seeing this film
and um i thought denzel was the coolest
man i'd ever seen in my life
and then also um i decided
after watching dakota who obviously was
so so talented from such a young age
um i decided that i want to be the
puerto rican version of her
so that's probably where it all started
i can't believe that's the movie
if all the things you were going to say
to me that was not what i was expecting
well there you go um i've been asking
this of everyone i've been talking to
you recently uh what tv
series would you love to guest star on
does it have to still be going or could
you i'll let you i'll let you do the
past
oh i would have i would have loved to be
on the office of course i feel like
that's an obvious answer but
i just want to have had a scene with um
creed bratton
and then steve carell i think that that
would have been really fun
and then also um it might be fun
or it would have been fun while new girl
was still happening to be
a part of new girl because i really love
nick miller on that
show and i just thank you the coolest
jake johnson thank you for that
got it what movie do you think you've
seen the most
movie that i've seen the most honestly
i don't really re-watch films but
growing up like
we had like a dvd player in our car and
we would just anytime like my family had
like soccer tournaments or whatever
would go
we had two films we had the pacifier
with vin diesel and we had over the
hedge which also another steve carrell
film
so over the edge may take the cake for
film
i've watched the most got it i have a
feeling jumping into why i get to talk
to you today
uh this yesterday thing i think as
families start to see it
the movie i definitely think there's
gonna be a lot of families that actually
do this
um it's gonna be one of those things
where i'm sure the kids are gonna
you know what i mean um so i'm just
curious uh do you
have your family since you made the
movie has your family been like we need
to go do this
no i mean and the reason why i say that
is a lot of my siblings because i'm 18
now
my um younger siblings are 16
i have siblings who are out at this
point yeah so we're all a bit older
i'm jealous of the kids who get to watch
this and
take on this idea because i wish this
was something that we had done
but i think that we kind of got to a
point in our life where we were past it
um but i i think looking back we can all
agree that
a yesterday would have been an amazing
experience
yeah i have a feeling a whole bunch of
families are about to experience this
uh the i want to get into the act some
specific scenes
so there's a scene where you and ever
the the family have to
eat a ton of ice cream and i'm just
curious what is it like as an actor
knowing
you're going to be doing a ton of takes
eating ice cream
unlike the first take are you allowing
yourself like how do you film that
without getting super sick
so fortunately i've had a lot of
experience with eating scenes before so
i've experienced the whole oh yeah no
we're
i'm gonna eat i love to eat this is
gonna be fine and then just feeling sick
and then still having to shoot and being
stuck with that i've done it i feel like
every actor has to learn it for
themselves almost
i don't think our younger brother or my
younger brother in the film julian
lerner
had had that experience yet because he
definitely went um he went ham on the
first day
and on the second day he was feeling it
um but me and myself i knew
to pace myself don't start off with the
ice cream maybe start off with like
the crunchy candies that will take you
longer to process
and you know you know so i i was very
calculated
i know that but also i remember um
the the younger kids julian and also
everly carganilla were really really
excited to shoot that
and i know me jen and edgar were kind of
nervous about it especially because it
was gonna be our first day shooting so
then we're gonna have to start off with
this like
sick feeling and then just keep going
and start riding roller coasters and
doing that whole thing
um so it was a little bit of a and also
it was like so complicated
shooting shooting-wise because we're
sitting on a round table so we knew that
it was going to be a
hefty scene for sure i can't believe
that was your first day filming
yeah yeah and i had just been working on
another prior and we were doing night
shoots so like we did a switch and i
think
in the other project um i had like a
little bit of a tattoo and i don't know
if it's still showing in the film
i think like i think that it got in like
because i literally was the next day
i don't know if i should have pointed
that out but uh i think it's an easter
egg yeah they're
yeah people who have watched the other
film are gonna recognize and be like oh
this is
this looks i see it uh but it literally
was like the day after i had wrapped the
previous film that i was doing that so
it was like still my sleep hours were
off and
that whole process was pretty crazy uh
you got to go
you literally got paid to ride roller
coasters
with jennifer garner in this movie um
have you thought about playing the
lottery because your luck seems to be
very good
i know i was just telling people earlier
today i was like i don't know how i got
so lucky because i was contractually
obligated
to ride these roller coasters to throw
water balloons at people
to sing on stages with jennifer garner
like it was just i don't
know i can't call it work um
i j i just i don't know i don't know
it's very rare that you get this lucky
and i think that
because it was such an insane experience
to film i've been saying too i think
that
it really translates in the film because
there's so much going on
uh there is you there is a moment where
you there's a
you're in a crowd scene and you're gonna
have to go up on stage and there's a ton
of people in the crowd
when you're acting with that many people
on set does it make you more nervous
or is it sort of like make you raise
your game
i wouldn't say that it makes me raise my
game the only time i'm ever really going
to be nervous to act is if
if it's with people i have a lot of
respect for so i guess like the first
few days with jennifer and edgar were a
little bit nerve-wracking because i
don't want them to think i suck
um but then also like working in a crowd
like that i'm fine with i've done
theater before
um the only time i'm really gonna get
like
so much anxiety isn't from performing in
front of my family
i cannot act in front of my family i i
never have been
i don't want to watch them see my work
like it's just
they've sacrificed so much so if they
think i'm bad then it's just not
i don't know it's ner it's it's like i
can't
i can see i even have a hard time
describing it uh
you are you you've wrapped on scream
and you are doing ty west's ex which are
like basically two horror projects
how did you uh land did you specifically
go after two horror movies like this or
was
how did both of these things happen no
it didn't
come up that way i remember i auditioned
for scream at the in the very beginning
of quarantine
like back in march and i auditioned for
a different character that i ended up
um working as but um
i auditioned for that i didn't hear
anything for months and months and
months and i didn't think i got it which
i wasn't surprised because i don't know
if you noticed i feel like it's pretty
obvious that oftentimes when teenagers
are cast in projects they're like 30
year olds
um so i just figured oh they're going to
cast people who are older and that's
just going to be it and they did cast
people or older i don't know how i
stepped into the mix but i did
so i was very very lucky for that and
they called me back a few months later
before i knew it
weeks later i was flying out to north
carolina to shoot that and then when i
was shooting scream
um i got the tape for um kai west's
project and it
see i mean it's outrageous um
so i was really really curious um to
send in a tape and see how that went and
then
i met with ty and ty and then also the
directors of scream matt and tyler just
so happen to be friends
so um i was on set or i was with matt
and tyler when i found out i booked the
project so they were like what you're
working with hi
that's so crazy so i don't know how i
ended up working with these up and
coming
horror directors back to back but i'm
very very lucky because horror has got
to be
the most fun projects to work on just
because you're there
purely for entertainment everybody's
there to have a good time and if you're
working in horror there's a good chance
you're a fan of horror
um so we're all just we're all just
really excited
i can ask you a million more questions
about scream but i gotta go and i know
you can't talk about it so i wish you
nothing but the best good luck with your
speed dating
thank you so much have a good rest here
today